what I want to do in this video is prove
that between any two rational numbers
between any two rational numbers so
let's say that's a rational number there
and then let's say that this is a this
is a another rational number that is
larger than this one right over here
that between any two rational numbers
you can find an irrational number you
can find an irrational number so that
number right over there is irrational
that you can find at least one
irrational number and that's kind of
crazy because there's a lot of rational
numbers there's an infinite number of
rational numbers so we're saying between
any two of those at between any two of
those rational numbers you can always
find an irrational number and we're
going to start thinking about it by just
thinking about the interval between 0 &
1 so if we think about the interval
between 0 & 1
we know that there are that there are
irrational numbers there in fact one of
them that might pop out at you is 1 over
the square root of 2 1 over the square
root of 2 which is the same thing as the
square root of 2 over 2 is equal I could
say equal is roughly it's approximately
equal to zero point 7 0 7 1 0 6 7 8 1 1
8 and and I could just keep going on and
on and on and on and on and on this
thing does not repeat but the important
point is it's clearly between 0 & 1 so I
could write 1 over the square root of 2
is clearly between 0 & 1
so the way that I'm going to prove that
there's an irrational number between any
two rational numbers is I'm going to
start with this set of inequalities I'm
going to manipulate it so I end up with
an r1 over here and an r2 over here and
then I would have from 1 over square
root of 2 I would have manipulated this
to construct at that irrational at least
one of the irrational numbers that's
between those two rational ones so let's
just let's just instead of making this
an interval between 0 & 1 let's make
this an interval between 0 and the
difference between these two
numbers so this the distance between r1
and r2 is r2 minus r1 so let's multiply
both sides of this inning all three
parts of this inequality I guess I could
say by r2 r2 minus r1 so let's do that
so if you multiply this zero times r2
minus r1 well you're just still going to
have zero there is less than and we know
that r2 is greater than R 1 so r2 - let
me let me make it clear what we're doing
we're going to multiply everything times
r2 minus r1 r2 we're assuming is greater
than R 1 so this thing right over here
is going to be greater than zero so if
you multiply the different the different
part the different sides of an
inequality by something greater than
zero you don't switch the inequality so
zero times that is 0 1 over square root
of 2 times that is going to be 1 over
the square root of 2 times our two times
times r2 r2 minus r1 minus r1 and then
that's going to be less than that's
going to be less than well 1 times that
is just going to be r2 that's just going
to be R 2 minus R 1 minus r1 and now now
we just have to kind of shift everything
over so let's add our 1 to L size of
this
so if we add something to all parts of
the inequality then that's also not
going to change the inequality so we're
going to add r1 over here we can add r1
over here and we could add r1 over there
and so on the left hand side we have R 1
is less than r1 plus let me just copy
and paste all of this so I don't have to
keep changing colors whoops that's not
what I wanted to do let me do this there
you go
all right that should be pretty good so
copy and paste that r1 Plus this Plus
that let me write the plus down plus
that is less than
is less than one it's a different shade
of blue is less than well what's what's
what's r1 plus r2 minus r1 well that's
just going to be r2 so I've just shown
you that you give me any two rational
numbers and I'm assuming R 2 is greater
than r1 I have just constructed an
irrational number that's going to be
between those two rational numbers you
take r1 you take the lower of the
rational numbers and to that you add 1
over square root of 2 times the
difference between those two rational
numbers and you are going to get this
right over here is an irrational
irrational number you're saying hey how
do I know that this thing how do I know
how can I be satisfied that this thing
is irrational well we've already seen
you take the product of an irrational
and a rational you get an irrational
number you take the sum of an irrational
number and a rational number you get an
irrational number so we've constructed
an irrational number based on the that's
between these two rationals